good morning John we're at the food farm
and we are here acquiring supplies for
the second annual hungry game which is
basically when some friends and I play a
stupid game and if you win the stupid
game you get to eat something delicious
stuffed inside of a dessert peanut
butter and if you lose you have to eat
something super terrible stuffed inside
a dessert this year instead of cookies
we're having brownies and instead of
just two contestants we're having three
myself Michael Aranda and Emily graslie
let's make some brownies making brownies
so there's two components to the hungry
games one is we're going to eat food
because we're hungry and two those fish
are also hungry for my fishing pole
there's a great deal on the line right
now don't I screw up suddenly yep not
excite you agree
I got like a million I feel nauseous
Monica laughing and we haven't even
eaten them just gonna not look and take
this one
hey brothers / gotcha it's pretty good
yeah I really like this ah I probably
get the rest of this actually and as a
trash can right here get right over it
maybe caviar taste good I'm gonna start
putting triage in all my brownies from
now on I'll try try em and then we'll
eat caviar brownie I kind of do ah ah
you know ah you like business smells
weird
ah this tastes like pink one this is
like nothing
no this tasted like reproductive organs
my reign supreme
ah that was a big bang you got right in
there he's all of it what I'm a fish
stick well dude I was kind of hoping for
that one holidays oh I really like fish
sticks right yeah right in there oh the
beans
I feel feel like I lucked out what do
you got peanut butter
ah all right all right sugar sugar sugar
Oh what is it
we're fryers oh yeah I didn't get that
one ah and then you like toaster heaven
instead of just chocolate and
horseradishes chocolate and horseradish
and spit movie going on in there oh I'm
so happy right now
you're handling it very well oh is it
not that's a little cheesy michael has
four five six seven eight nine ten I
think we got the piece I got the strap
mine has spam in it three two one a
negative feeling about this
Oh somebody's wrong way bit hard on
all I can think about at this point is
how are we gonna outdo this for next
glad you're ready for this to happen
next year
what am i doing thank you for joining me
though Michael and Emily thank you to
Stefan for filming this was a delicious
evening interspersed with really
terrible experiences goodbye John
see you up Tuesday